New details about that second
grand jury
that's been meeting in the Trump
classified documents investigation.
Sources say that
this jury, which is based in
southern Florida,
has heard testimony
from multiple witnesses
in recent weeks
and is set to hear
from at least two more witnesses.
Let's get straight to CNN's
Kristen
Holmes is breaking this for us Kristen.
So this is in the same jurisdiction
where the search warrant for Mar
a Lago was approved. Tell us more.
That's right.
So what we know so far
is that this grand jury
has been meeting
in a courthouse in Miami,
and they have recently heard,
as you said,
from a number of witnesses,
they are expected to hear
from another witness
in this investigation
into the classified probes tomorrow.
And after that, at least
one more witness.
Now, what's not clear is why exactly
they have this second grand jury.
And I talked to a number of sources
close to Trump
who said that they were also unsure
why this grand jury was convening,
why they were hearing the case.
One thing to note is that Jack
Smith has the authority
as a special counsel
to operate and bring charges
in any jurisdiction.
So this is completely within his purview.
Now, as you mentioned,
there was the person,
the court that signed off
on that search warrant for Mar
a Lago
was in the Southern District in Florida.
The other thing about that
it's interesting
is the US, an assistant U.S.
attorney from the Miami
bureau, was present
when that search was executed in Mar
a Lago.
And one thing to bring up here
is that there have been questions
about venue
since before the special counsel
even took over this investigation
because it dealt with taking documents
from the White House
to Trump's Florida Florida resort.
So that has always been up.
But again, it's still unclear
why exactly.
They they are
have convened the second grand jury, why
they have our hearing
excuse me,
why they have bringing witnesses
in front of the second grand jury, Jake.
All right.
Kristen Holmes with that breaking news
Thanks so much.
Let's bring in
CNN senior legal
analyst and former
federal prosecutor
Ali Hornick to talk about this Ali.
Up until now,
we've only known of the one
grand jury in the Trump
documents case,
the grand jury here in Washington, D.C.
But now we're hearing more
because of our great reporters
about multiple witnesses
testifying to a grand jury in Florida.
What could that mean for this case?
Well, Jake, it's
a really interesting development.
I see two broad possibilities.
One is
this could be a convenience measure
if there are certain witnesses
who can't or won't travel
outside of Florida.
What you can do as a prosecutor
is take their testimony
in a federal grand jury down there
and then take the transcripts
and just read it to your main grand
jury in D.C..
The other possibility is prosecutors
could be examining
the possibility of charging this case
down in the southern district of Florida.
They would have the ability to do that.
Prosecutors, when you have a crime,
you have to charge it in
one of the districts
where some of the criminal
conduct occurred.
You do have some leeway as a prosecutor,
but you have to get it right.
If you charged in the wrong district,
the case will get thrown out.
So theoretically,
could it be some sort of criminal charge?
And I'm just speculating here.
So but some sort of criminal charge
having to do with holding the documents
improperly in Florida
and then the obstruction of justice
charge in Washington, D.C.,
something like that, would there.
Would they charge
in two different jurisdictions
at the same time?
Theoretically, you can do that,
but I do not think prosecutors
would do that.
That would be a practical
and logistical mess.
You then have two cases
in two different courtrooms.
You'd have to have to trials
going on at the same time.
I think prosecutors are going to have
to essentially decide,
are we charging this in D.C. or Florida?
Now, the advantage to D.C.
for prosecutors, let's just be real here
Donald Trump is very unpopular.
He got 5.4% of the vote in D.C.
in 20, 20.
The jury pool is going to be way better
for prosecutors in D.C.
But venue is clearer to me in Florida
because that's where the documents
were kept, that
certainly where the obstructive
acts occurred.
And so if they charge in D.C.,
they do run the risk of
not having the proper venue here,
which is a very high stakes risk.
Although you could argue
that if they get
an indictment in Florida,
it will have more credibility
because that's a state
that Donald Trump won twice.
We know
Trump's lawyers met
with Justice Department
officials yesterday.
The defense lawyers ever succeed
in changing prosecutors minds
when they have these meetings,
they're obviously trying
to convince them
to not pursue an indictment against Mr.
Trump.
I would say rarely, but not never.
There are times
when prosecutors already have
their minds made up.
But you still give the defense lawyer
the meeting as a professional courtesy.
But there are cases
where it's a close call
where a powerful, persuasive,
substantive presentation
by defense
lawyers can convince prosecutors
not to charge or to charge
less serious conduct.
I'll tell you,
there were times
when I was persuaded as a prosecutor,
but if I had to put a number on,
I would say
it's in the low
single digit of percentages.
All right, Leonnig, thanks so much.
Appreciate it.